[Música]
[Aplausos]
entonces si alguna vez han visto a los
gansos emigrar sí no esta es la
formación que lleva a que alguna
formación como effect esto hace que sus
viajes tan largos sean más eficientes
pueden aumentar su poder de vuelo hasta
un 70 por ciento a comparación que si
para cada uno volando solo
cuando el líder se cansa se pasa hacia
atrás para poder descansar esto abrió un
espacio para que otro de los dances pase
adelante a tomar este rol de líder
deberá entonces se comparten el
liderazgo y así es como logran llegar
tan lejos si por alguna razón alguno de
los gansos se pueda salir de esa
formación rápido se volvería a meter
porque siente la resistencia del aire y
no tiene sentido no aprovecharse el
trabajo que están haciendo los demás
verá
[Música]
eso no quiere decir que si no van en la
punta no van aportando al equipo los que
van atrás van haciendo cosas a los que
van adelante y eso motiva a que los de
adelante pues sigan rompiendo el viento
ahora y sigan avanzando y así
cuando estaba creciendo
y sentía cómo presión de afuera como
mujer que no podía seguir adelante sola
y me puse a pensar mi último año de
secundaria que era lo que yo quería para
mi vida el deporte era una parte muy
importante y quería que siguiera siendo
una parte muy importante de ella pero me
fijaba por ejemplo en
en hogares tradicionales la mujer se
enfocaba en criar a los hijos por
ejemplo y el hombre en proveer a la
familia en el colegio me tocó verlo
cuando me tocó escoger dos clases estaba
entre entre aeróbicos donde la mayoría
de mujeres se metían y deportes por
equipo donde la mayoría de hombres se
metían a mí me encanta jugar fútbol y
entonces y ahora de las pocas mujeres
que estaban en esta clase de deportes
por equipos cuando cuando llegué al
final de la secundaria me empecé a
preguntar qué era lo que yo quería para
mi vida y me di cuenta que el deporte
era una gran parte de eso era tenía la
suerte de que mi papá mi abuelo eran
ciclistas entonces tenía acceso a la
bici y así empezó mi pasión
empezó como hobby y poco a poco le fui
le fui poniendo más estructura
a este hobby y me tocó dejar de hacer
cosas con mis amigas me tocó dejar de
salir a parrandear por ejemplo que era
lo que la mayoría de gente media estaba
haciendo entonces al meterle más
estructura me fui dando cuenta de lo
demandante y de lo solitario que podía
llegar a ser este estilo de vida de ver
a este es de este deporte empecé como
selección nacional juvenil y me tocaba
viajar a competencias me tocaba viajar
en entrenamientos y
y como les decía a ver me fui dando
cuenta que la bici era mi motor en
búsqueda de ese camino
[Música]
me dio mucha seguridad y me dio
independencia porque pasaba tanto tiempo
sola
también me hizo darme cuenta de las
habilidades que tenía sobre la bici y
pues en mi día a día y cuando logré
fijar metas y usar esas habilidades esas
fortalezas que tenía
para empezar a formar mi camino
empecé a llevar mis límites más lejos de
ahora cada vez con las herramientas
correctas y con esa seguridad que me dio
la bici me di cuenta que también podía
ser líder dentro de ese tema de equipo
verdad
entre más cerca de gente que tenía los
mismos valores que yo estaba más fácil
se volvía a alcanzar estas metas y me di
cuenta que al rodearme de gente que
pensaba igual que yo y que tenía metas
similares podía alcanzar cosas más
grandes que yo voy a ser parte de cosas
que yo solas no podía lograr
en el 2011 empecé a competir con la
selección nacional juvenil y como les
decía le fui metiendo más más estructura
a esa pasión y eso me llevó a competir
para la universidad de colorado del 2012
el 2016
cada año en la universidad
le fui metiendo más tiempo y las
competencias se fueron poniendo más
duras entonces eso quería decir que yo
tenía que dar más de mí para poder
seguir mejorando y al final de mi
carrera tenía la opción de seguir por el
rumbo de la bici y dar ese paso a
volverme atleta alto rendimiento como
trabajo como profesión o irme a un banco
o irme a una oficina que es lo más
normal ver a
gracias a dios escogió la bici
[Música]
[Aplausos]
estoy segura que aunque no sepa mucho el
ciclismo han oído hablar del tour de
france es una de las competencias más
exigentes y más famosas del mundo muy
prestigiosa el equipo típico silicom
valley dan con que firme al graduarme en
la universidad me dio el chance de ser
parte del equipo que iba a competir en
el 2017 en el tour de france yo diría
que el factor más importante que me
llevo a ese nivel de de ciclismo y que
me permitió llegar al tour de france y
pues aportar a un equipo y dar lo mejor
de mí fue la perseverancia
me tocó caerme y me tocó aprender a
levantarme
en mi caso eran caídas físicas me dejó
dejar el pellejo saber bien cuántas
calles y pues tengo un par de clavos acá
que me van a acompañar todo el resto de
mi vida de una caída muy fuerte que tuve
para mí y para muchos ciclistas de los
retos más difíciles es aprender a
levantarse de era porque no no sólo es
físico eso es el que menos duele el
emocional el espiritual el mental
hay muchas caídas verán pero saber de
dar ese paso para adelante para seguir
motivando pse y seguir avanzando
es muy importante a este ganso de aquí
le tocó atravesar el océano atlántico
hasta el col d'izoard que es donde fue
la competencia del tour de france
femenino este año eran 67 kilómetros y
muy duros no sólo por el tipo de
corredores que iban sino también por la
altura que eran entonces es más difícil
respirar y es más difícil votar y si uno
siente que se mueve y se queda sin aire
y
y entonces para prepararnos para esta
competencia el director técnico nos
sentó a las seis que íbamos a participar
y empezamos a hablar de la estrategia
que íbamos a usar y empezamos a discutir
el perfil de la carrera estos son los
últimos 20 kilómetros les pongo un
ejemplo si ustedes creen que subir el
acatenango es difícil y se están
muriendo y ya no quieren que enter la
toalla pues no tienen idea esta pared
era así salió cuando la vi porque la
manejamos en un carro antes de recorrer
la casa muy bueno y si yo no voy a poder
pues hoy empieza el reto de pararse y
seguir avanzando y todo eso gracias a
ellos tenía un equipo muy bueno y lo que
hicimos entonces ahora la parte de la
estrategia vimos el perfil y lo
separamos
los separamos
para poder darle acá a cada integrante
del equipo la parte que más se le daba a
mí la parte que más se me daba era el
principio los primeros 20 kilómetros
digamos entonces mi trabajo era romper
el viento y asegurarme que mis
compañeros no estuvieran en la punta
ellas estaban atrás de mí entonces viene
echando punta delante y cuando ya
terminé mi trabajo me hice a un lado
obviamente me dejó tocar
dejar mi ego a un lado porque
porque pues cuando me hice a un lado ya
no estaba cansada ya no ya no tenía para
más dejé miedo a un lado entonces y me
sacrifiqué por el equipo por decirlo así
pero cuando yo me hice una pase para
atrás para descansar para recuperarme
otra de mis compañeras pasó al frente y
empezó a hacer lo mismo que estaba
haciendo yo a romper el viento
asegurarse que el resto estuvieran
protegidas y así como equipo logramos un
séptimo un séptimo lugar mi compañera
logró llegar al final gracias al trabajo
en equipo que hicimos nosotros los
recibimos el viento y pues ella logró un
buen resultado nos agradeció mucho
porque sin nosotros ella no hubiera
logrado llegar hasta este punto era fue
gracias al que el resto del equipo de
juego han dado y nos supimos unir bien y
comunicar bien y todos teníamos los
mismos valores y metas y en fin
entonces ya cuando yo me hice a un lado
igual todavía tenía que llegar a la
punta tenía que terminar y entonces el
recorrido a mí se me salían las lágrimas
de la emoción y de la pasión de ver a
toda esta gente que nos estaba viendo y
apoyando yo nunca había vivido algo así
nunca había sentido y es marcar a todos
todo lo que sentí ese día
y no logramos lograr
sin este trabajo en equipo era
me puse a pensar eso dichosa que era
tener una familia que me había apoyado
hacen mis sueños
y me puse a pensar lo lindo que sería
poder compartir esto con gente de aouate
algún día tener un equipo de puras
mujeres y poder pues representar al país
y sentir todo lo que os sentía ese día
no se ve muy bien pero les presenta
rafael
él es mi fiel acompañante mi bici la que
me ha enseñado todo lo que hice
e
me di cuenta con rafael que que las tres
cosas que me ayudaron a llegar donde
estoy hoy son en conocerme a mí misma
manera el saber cuáles son mis
habilidades cuáles son mis fortalezas
que me gusta que no me gusta mis valores
pero eso es muy importante en el saber
que como mujer podía ser ciclista
profesional porque tenía esa confianza y
esa seguridad en mí que no tenía que
seguir lo que la gente decía que por ser
mujer tenía que hacer pues me dio esa
seguridad para poder después usar mis
fortalezas sin ponerme metas para ayudar
a un equipo para poder llegar más lejos
ver cosas más grandes y ser parte de
algo más grande que mis metas
individuales
al fijar al ponerme esas metas y hacer
perseverante a levantarme aunque hubiera
sangre aunque hubiera lo que fuera logré
llegar hasta donde estoy hoy y entonces
es muy importante darse cuenta lo que
uno necesita para ser exitoso y eso es
diferente para todos veras pero para
llegar a cumplir cosas más grandes
que como un individual era hacerlo como
grupo y eso es lo que quería compartir
con ustedes así que los invito a que
seamos los mejores gansos que podamos
hacer
gracias
[Música]
ah